ist jetzt mittlerweile fertig nach zwei
monaten oder so ich hab schon gedacht da
wird nichts mehr kommen aber es kam was
es ist jetzt fertig und ich würde sagen
wir reden jetzt einfach nicht mehr lange
um den heißen brei herum
hier ist mein neues intro servus kids
von herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video in dem wir heute mal jump league
spielen mal wieder richtig der bestes
spiel modus sowie wenn ich ein spiel
modus wäre und der beste wäre ja und
heute darf ich endlich mein neues intro
vorstellen aber leute erst möchte ich
euch mal zwei geschichten erzählen
ich werde euch heute in diesem video
zeigen ihr bekommt zu sehen nicht vor
dem video indes wertvoller und easy und
reckt sondern im im laufe des videos
irgendwann wenn ich die vorgeschichte
dazu erzählt ob das will ich noch ganz
gern machen und davor leute was ist
gestern passiert also ich erzähle ich
erstmal wie momentan meine woche in
berlin so aussieht ich arbeite hat den
ganzen tag von da bin ich so von halb
neun bis 19 uhr unterwegs
dann komme ich nach hause und meistens
sieht so aus ich komm nach hause bin
mehr oder weniger erschöpft von der
arbeit uns geht direkt an den pc und uns
aufnehmen für den nächsten tag und dann
direkt ans schneiden und wenn ich
zwischen ich noch ein bisschen sport
mache da wie kann ich glücklich sein
dass es eher die ausnahme weil es dafür
keine zeit gibt aber weil ich dafür
keine power habe also arbeiten und
nebenbei noch youtube ist richtig
anstrengend
vorausgesetzt man wer täglich hochwimmer
jetzt den dritten hochlädt dann geht's
ein billig aber man jeden tag hoch wären
dann noch bisschen seine videos
schneider zu gibt es in den letzten
tagen gemacht habe und wie ich mich auch
ziemlich bock macht dann ist es fucking
zeitintensiv und das ist richtig
anstrengend man kommt zu nichts mehr in
seinem restlichen leben was mich auch
ein bisschen stress aber hey es ist
einfach so muss man klar von auf jeden
fall führt das dazu dass ich dann abends
bis zwei oder drei einen videos setzte
am nächsten tag dann um 8 auf stehe
und dann habe ich in der regel so 55
einhalb stunden schlaf und wenn ich das
mal eine woche lang mache tagsüber auch
noch aktiv bin dann bin ich am ende der
woche einfach fucking fertig und so sah
es gestern noch aus ich war fertig so
und dann musste ich aber noch etwas was
ich musste meine familie hat gemeint ja
wir haben dieses wochen an den straßen
fest
schaut doch mal vorbei und ich gehen
beide familie gerne wer macht das nicht
es gibt ein paar aber ich sehe meine
familie gerne und habe ich mir okay dann
kommst du nach hause
aber ich war ja bis freitag 18 uhr 30
noch im büro das heißt wie kommt man
nach hause
es sind fünf stunden fahrt sechs stunden
sogar mit dem auto heißt wie komme ich
da irgendwie nach hause
mitfahrgelegenheit habe ich erst gedacht
da habe ich etwas rausgesucht da gab es
nicht also gab's nichts passendes für
mich die fahren alle früher später oder
generell zu zeiten an denen ich nicht
brauchen kann
also habe ich mir ja okay dann auch noch
in berlin fest mit einem auto nach hause
sechs stunden und ich sage euch leute es
war eine tortur macht sowas nicht nach
einer langen anstrengenden woche mit zu
wenig schlaf noch mal sechs stunden auf
die autobahn ist einfach eine tortur das
ist folter qual
ein leiden was auch immer macht es
einfach nicht es war richtig richtig
anstrengend aber ich habe es geschafft
es ist auch aus was die sicherheit
angeht nicht besonders
verantwortungsvoll war nicht da naja ich
werde dich fast eingepennt aber ich habe
schon ein paar kritische momente also
versucht einfach erst gar nicht wenn
ihren führerschein habt macht so ein
käse nicht das war einfach dumm
aber ich musste halt irgendwie nach
hause zu meiner familie oder ich wollte
ja das macht man also alles klar das war
die geschichte zu heute ich kann man
gestern so um halb vier zu hause an den
instant ins bett und direkt weg gepennt
bis heute mittag 14 uhr deswegen kommt
das video vielleicht ein bisschen später
leid was als ob dem ziel du du verarscht
nicht doch man immer diese jump league
sucht dies alle auf den hacker leute
bleiben hätten ohne also perfekt doch
nicht nach vorne oder so das war aber
die sache jetzt kommen wir als ob er die
map in drei minuten gemacht hat what the
[ __ ] das ist doch nicht sein ernst
altert das ist doch nicht so ernst aber
hey leute das war wieder geschichte zum
besten tage jetzt was mich weitermachen
mit der geschichte zum intro ich hatte
ja sehr lange kein intro das sind sicher
einige von euch bemerkt und amis der typ
her komm geh weg klar
danke dass du mich getötet hat er sehr
lange kein intro obwohl ich eigentlich
ein intro haben wollte aber mich hat
einfach kein interesse haben viele leute
geschrieben
ja ich würde gerne intro machen und ich
habe immer gesagt sehr gern
ich freue mich immer wenn leute mir
introns machen schickt mir das zu finde
ich cool so aber meistens wasser dann
einfach nicht gut weil kanada und die
quali war vernichtet dann hab ich ja
ganz okay ich möchte jetzt nicht
irgendein case intro ich habe mein
letztes intro bewusst nicht mehr genutzt
weil es mir nicht mehr gefallen hat und
wenn ich jetzt neues möchte habe möchte
ich dass es gut ist und lange haben wir
die leute die gesagt habe ich mich der
intro machen
nicht so die qualität abgeliefert die
ich gerne haben möchte man im channel
deswegen hatte ich auch lange kann intro
und ich hab ja auch irgendwie nicht so
den überblick mich dann selbst daran zu
setzen und after effects zu lernen oder
so oder auch für ein intro zu bezahlen
wenn ihr auch bisschen komisch weil
meine tweets 2000 euro wert sind wie ihr
vielleicht wisst ja und deswegen hat es
eine weile gedauert bis mein neues intro
kam alles klar
dann hat sie aber irgendeiner gemeldet
das war halt einer von den verschiedenen
22.000 aber so 45 leute die gesagt haben
macht den intro ich habe diesmal wie
gesagt gemalt ja gerne und der letzte
war länder liebe wilson way wechsel
wollten
er hat gemeint ich mach dir auch ein
intro und meint er könnte das relativ
gut hab ich gesagt ja klar gerne sag mal
was du kannst du dich natürlich nicht
gesagt aber ihr wisst was ich meine
leute und dann hat das halt sich daran
gemacht den tod zu machen
hey hey ich will absterben glauben geilo
okay sagt nehme das thema des naimo
autos und schönen
und das hat dann relativ lange gedauert
muss man sagen wahrscheinlich einfach
deswegen weil er selbst auch viel zu tun
hat hat er gemeint aber es ist jetzt
mittlerweile fertig nach zwei monaten
oder so ich hab schon gedacht da wird
nichts mehr kommen aber es kam was es
ist jetzt fertig und ich würde sagen wir
reden jetzt einfach nicht mehr lange um
den heißen brei herum
hier ist mein neues intro
so sieht's aus wie gefällt euch schreibt
das gerne mal die kommentare und gerne
auch noch feedback falls ihr hat sich
irgendwas einfach dass man spontan dran
ändern könnte
als ob ich jetzt sicherlich gegen zwei
möglichkeiten bank pictet gestoppt conti
cong.de hinter die irischen bonds de ja
klar conti kerns dem komplott fakt was
der hektar alter [ __ ] was war dass wir
jetzt alle hab ich jetzt auch mal ein
das ist ein gestaltet ist dass
eingeschlafen mein fuß mein fuß ist
ich schwöre euch meine weynfeldt gleich
ab das ist so krass eingeschlafen grad
eben okay was erwarte ich wenn ich mich
drauf setzte aber ich hab mir wie
komisch drauf gesetzt mehr leute auf
jeden fall das war so wissen die
geschichte zu dem intro und das intro
ist jetzt da eure meinung ist gefragt
was haltet ihr davon
nur ein mal den kommentar kommentarbox
wer kommen möchte mal lange jahren ja
nicht dass liebe wellen sogar an dem
combo ausgepackt werden
hoffmann warum kann ich nicht angeln ich
kann nicht angeklagt vier herzen
nein zwei herzen erwarte ich hab doch
ein bogen wo erst mal ist erst mal essen
essen ich hab kein bock hierzu ultra
krieg zu sterben als man hier leider
kann ich einen schönen weg spam
ja das ist die geschichte einer sache
nicht auch noch erzählen wollte kleiner
fun fact dieses t shirt was ich gerade
an habe hat welche farbe leute falsch es
ist nicht weiß es ist gelb und ihr seht
vielleicht es ist ein bisschen richtig
cool hier könnte wissen dahinter die die
minecraft gesehen halte ich mein t
shirts einfach gelb und aus irgendeinem
grund rendert dass mein pc oder maxis pc
heraus
jetzt habe ich einfach durchsichtiges t
shirt achte mal drauf mein t shirt
sicher die häuser dahinter die bewegen
sich zimmer kann dadurch sehen will ich
so ich glaube dieser konstanz ii hat
suchen bis zu sechs drin vielleicht kann
das sein
da hat mir ein bisschen sehr schnell ich
jetzt wie geben wir wenn es gleich mal
ausprobieren okay wenn wir erst mal
feiern wir können hier bisschen chillen
alte mein wein ist so eingeschlafen es
ist die hölle ich gehe mal hier ein
kambodschanischer einkesselte da hinten
ist einer von einbiegt der herr mich
nicht bitte herr mich nicht tot er
riecht ist ein tolles gefühl
übrigens ja ich habe es gerade eben
schon so indirekt gesagt das ist nicht
mein pc hier sondern maxis pc weil ich
nicht in berlin bin das erkennt man auch
im hintergrund das erkennt man facetime
rahmens erkennbaren texture pack sondern
an maxis pc und jetzt hier ein marxist
pc für euch dieses video aufnehmen
super busy hashtag mächtig und so kam
ich erst noch weg ja hat es gesehen
locker ist er am hacken locker also er
hat nock weg aber habt ihr diese double
jetzt gesehen richtig komisch was ist
los mit diesem jungen
ich versteh's nicht kurz zum verteiler
eindrücken über schlechte war richtig
schlecht dachte er läuft weiter außen
rum
ok anfall jetzt mal in den nahkampf ja
locker hätte er locker ich diese hits an
alter du feldmann heck doch nicht
heckmann anders nicht meine aufnahme wie
spacex greift nicht an bitte stoppt mich
nicht ab achtung der hacker kommt
achtung achtung achtung achtung kommt
man hier könnt ihr das master aus der
nähe anschauen
es sieht sehr stark nach rechts aussen
alle schreiben auch hexe das nicht dass
der zufall es ehrlich gesagt ja wisst
ihr was ich würde erstmal dann werde ich
ein bisschen dann spiele ich vielleicht
auf winner oder wohin super kreativen an
die spieler auf durch zeit also als ohne
ich konnte meine tochter das ist schon
einfach weiß raus gewandert wird
aber hey spitzenjobs camp von der
facetime rahmen ist
grün also müsste eigentlich grün raus
ländern nicht gelb aber aus irgendeinem
grund hatte sich dazu entschieden gelb
auszuwandern
ramon ram und wo ist die mitte da hinten
ist die mittel ok wären jetzt herein
bis jetzt ja klar also ganz ehrlich
ergibt die ganze zeit so komisch jetzt
die komisch nein nach hat er mich
gekillt alter schöne hexe titel was war
das für eine runde schöne hexe brennt
ich hab so viel aufgenommen falls seiner
kompletten team sieht band den guten und
lassen